brains they are coming for us
in the suite mercy
are you hmm
good question now here's what i do know
i seem to have traveled here via time
travel capsule there's no such thing as
time travel
i came here because something very big
is set to occur and it needs to be
stopped
introducing the brotherhood of evil very
evil right
she must be eliminated
we'll be ready in the meantime
our presence here will go completely
unnoticed
wasn't the brotherhood of evil defeated
yeah we have bigger problems the
sisterhood of dada
do you want to find and corral them
actually
i'd like you to kill them
you're not the kind of people that kill
people we've got our own crap to take
care of remember what's going on here
babe
they can't just shut me down you say
there's something wrong with rain
[Music]
come on you want to be the chiefs badass
crime fighting doom patrol but that's
just not who we are
they are coming for us this
is everyone's problem
we've been here before battered bruised
but we lick our wounds and rise from the
ashes stronger than ever before are you
seriously trying to give us a rally
speech right now oh yeah because you
just have to fake it till you make it
you have a second chance sometimes you
have to set worlds on fire so you can
make something new
toad bonnet b
thatcher's blue buff code bonnet b
that's yours i am so high
[Music]
you